NONE CHANGED THE RESULTS.
AND IN SOME OF THE IRONY, THE
MARGIN OF VICTORY GREW SLIGHTLY.
LET'S SPEAK PLAINLY ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN 2020.
EVEN BEFORE THE FIRST BALLOT WAS
CAST, THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS
PREEMPTIVELY SEWING DOUBT ABOUT
THE ELECTION RESULTS.
HE BUILT HIS LIE OVER MONTHS,
WASN'T BASED IN ANY FACTS.
HE WAS JUST LOOKING FOR AN
EXCUSE, A PRETEXT, TO COVER FOR
THE TRUTH.
HE'S NOT JUST A FORMER
PRESIDENT.
HE'S A DEFEATED FORMER
DEFEATED BY A MARGIN OF OVER 7
MILLION OF YOUR VOTES.
A FULL AND FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
THERE IS SIMPLY ZERO PROOF THE
ELECTION RESULTS WERE
INACCURATE.
IN FACT, IN EVERY VENUE, WHERE
EVIDENCE HAD TO BE PRODUCED, AN
OATH TO TELL THE TRUTH HAD TO BE
TAKEN, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
FAILED TO MAKE HIS CASE.
JUST THINK ABOUT THIS.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS HAVE NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO EXPLAIN HOW THEY ACCEPT AS
ACCURATE THE OTHER ELECTION
RESULTS THAT TOOK PLACE ON
NOVEMBER 3rd.
THE ELECTIONS FOR GOVERNOR,
UNITED STATES SENATE, HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, ELECTIONS WHICH
THEY CLOSED THE GAP IN THE
HOUSE.
THEY CHALLENGED NONE OF THAT.
THE PRESIDENT'S NAME WAS FIRST,
THEN WE WENT DOWN THE LINE.
GOVERNOR, SENATORS, HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, SOMEHOW THOSE
RESULTS WERE ACCURATE ON THE
SAME BALLOT, BUT THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE WAS FLAWED?
ON THE SAME BALLOT, THE SAME
DAY, CAST BY THE SAME VOTERS.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DIDN'T LOSE THOSE
RACES, HE JUST LOST THE ONE THAT
WAS HIS OWN.
FINALLY, THE THIRD BIG LIE BEING
TOLD BY A FORMER PRESIDENT AND
HIS SUPPORTERS, THAT THE MOB WHO
SOUGHT TO IMPOSE THEIR WILL
THROUGH VIOLENCE ARE THE
NATION'S TWO PATRIOTS.
IS THAT WHAT YOU THOUGHT?
WHEN YOU LOOKED AT THE MOB,
RANSACKING THE CAPITOL,
DESTROYING PROPERTY, LITERALLY
DEFECATING IN THE HALLWAYS.
RIGHTFULLY AND THROUGH THE
DEATHS OF SENATORS AND
REPRESENTATIVES, HUNTING DOWN
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, PATRIOTS,
NOT IN MY VIEW.
TO ME, THE TRUE PATRIOTS WERE
THE MORE THAN 150 AMERICANS WHO
PEACEFULLY EXPRESSED THEIR VOTE
AT THE BALLOT BOX.
THE ELECTION WORKERS WHO
PROTECTED THE INTEGRITY OF THE
VOTE.
AND THE HEROES WHO DEFENDED THIS
CAPITOL.
YOU CAN'T LOVE YOUR COUNTRY ONLY
WHEN YOU WIN.
YOU CAN'T OBEY THE LAW ONLY WHEN
IT IS CONVENIENT.
YOU CAN'T BE PATRIOTIC WHEN YOU
EMBRACE AND ENABLE LIES.
THOSE WHO STORMED THIS CAPITOL
AND THOSE WHO INSTIGATED AND
INCITED AND THOSE WHO CALLED ON
THEM TO DO SO HELD A DAGGER AT
THE THROAT OF AMERICA, AT
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
THEY DIDN'T COME HERE OUT OF
PATRIOTISM OR PRINCIPLE.
THEY CAME HERE IN RAGE.
NOT IN SERVICE OF AMERICA, BUT
RATHER IN SERVICE OF ONE MAN.
THOSE WHO INCITED THE MOB, THE
REAL PLOTTERS WHO WERE DESPERATE
TO DENY THE CERTIFICATION OF
THIS ELECTION, DEFY THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS, BUT THEIR PLOT WAS
FOILED.
CONGRESSMEN, DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS, STAYED.
SENATORS, REPRESENTATIVES,
STAFF, THEY FINISHED THEIR WORK
THE CONSTITUTION DEMANDED.
THEY HONORED THEIR OATH TO
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST
ALL ENEMIES, FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC.
LOOK, FOLKS, NOW IT IS UP TO ALL
OF US TO WE, THE PEOPLE, TO
STAND FOR THE RULE OF LAW, TO
PRESERVE THE FLAME OF DEMOCRACY,
TO KEEP THE PROMISE OF AMERICA
ALIVE.
THAT PROMISE IS AT RISK,
TARGETED BY THE FORCES THAT
VALUE BRUTE STRENGTH OVER THE
SANCTITY OF DEMOCRACY.
FEAR OVER HOPE.
PERSONAL GAIN OVER PUBLIC GOOD.
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT, WE'RE
LIVING AT AN INFLEXION POINT IN
HISTORY.
BOTH HOME AND ABROAD, WE'RE
ENGAGED ANEW IN A STRUGGLE
BETWEEN DEMOCRACY AND AUTOCRACY.
BETWEEN THE ASPIRATIONS OF THE
MANY AND THE GREED OF THE FEW.
BETWEEN THE PEOPLE'S RIGHT OF
SELF-DETERMINATION AND
SELF-SEEKING AUTOCRAT.
FROM CHINA TO RUSSIA AND BEYOND,
THEY'RE BETTING THAT DEMOCRACY'S
DAYS ARE NUMBERED.
TOLD ME DEMOCRACY IS TOO SLOW,
TOO BOGGED DOWN BY DIVISION, TO
SUCCEED IN TODAY'S RAPIDLY
CHANGING COMPLICATED WORLD.
AND THEY'RE BETTING, THEY'RE
BETTING AMERICA WILL BECOME MORE
LIKE THEM AND LESS LIKE US.
THEY'RE BETTING THAT AMERICA IS
A PLACE FOR THE AUTOCRAT, THE
DICTATOR, THE STRONG MAN.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT.
THAT IS NOT WHO WE ARE.
THAT IS NOT WHO WE HAVE EVER
BEEN.
AND THAT IS NOT WHO WE SHOULD
EVER, EVER BE.
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS, AS
IMPERFECT AS THEY WERE, SET A
MOTION AND EXPERIMENT THAT
CHANGED THE WORLD, LITERALLY
CHANGED THE WORLD.
HERE IN AMERICA, THE PEOPLE
WOULD RULE.
POWER WOULD BE TRANSFERRED
PEACEFULLY.
NEVER AT THE TIP OF A SPEAR OR A
BARREL OF A GUN.
AND THEY COMMITTED TO PAPER AN
IDEA THAT COULDN'T LIVE UP TO --
THEY COULDN'T LIVE UP TO, BUT AN
IDEA THAT COULDN'T BE
CONSTRAINED.
YES, IN AMERICA, ALL PEOPLE ARE
CREATED EQUAL.
REJECT THE VIEW THAT IF YOU
SUCCEED, I FAIL.
IF YOU GET AHEAD, I FALL BEHIND.
IF I HOLD YOU DOWN, I SOMEHOW
LIFT MYSELF UP.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WHO LIES
ABOUT THIS ELECTION AND THE MOB
THAT ATTACKED THIS CAPITOL COULD
NOT BE FURTHER AWAY FROM THE
CORE AMERICAN VALUES.
THEY WANT TO RULE OR THEY WILL
RUIN.
RUIN WHAT OUR COUNTRY FOUGHT FOR
AT LEXINGTON AND CONCORD, AT
GETTYSBURG AND OMAHA BEACH,
SENECA FALLS, SELMA, ALABAMA.
AND WHAT WE'RE FIGHTING FOR.
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
THE RIGHT TO GOVERN OURSELVES.
THE RIGHT TO DETERMINE OUR OWN
DESTINY.
WITH RIGHTS COME
RESPONSIBILITIES, RESPONSIBILITY
TO SEE EACH OTHER AS NEIGHBORS,
MAYBE WE DISAGREE WITH THAT
NEIGHBOR, BUT THEY'RE NOT AN
ADVERSARY.
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACCEPT DEFEAT,
THEN GET BACK INTO THE ARENA AND
TRY AGAIN THE NEXT TIME TO MAKE
YOUR CASE.
RESPONSIBILITY TO SEE THAT
AMERICA IS AN IDEA, AN IDEA THAT
REQUIRES VIGILANT STEWARDSHIP.
AS WE STAND HERE TODAY, ONE YEAR
SINCE JANUARY 6th, 2021, THE
LIES THAT DROVE THE ANGER AND
MADNESS WE SAW IN THIS PLACE,
THEY HAVE NOT ABATED.
SO WE HAVE TO BE FIRM, RESOLUTE
AND UNYIELDING IN OUR DEFENSE OF
THE RIGHT TO VOTE, AND TO HAVE
THAT VOTE COUNTED.
SOME HAVE ALREADY MADE THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE IN THIS
SACRED EFFORT.
JILL AND I HAVE MOURNED POLICE
OFFICERS IN THIS CAPITOL
ROTUNDA, NOT ONCE, BUT TWICE, IN
THE WAKE OF JANUARY OF 6th, ONCE
FOR BRIAN SICKNICK WHO LOST HIS
LIFE THE DAY AFTER THE ATTACK,
AND SECOND TIME TO HONOR OFFICER
BILLY EVANS WHO LOST HIS LIFE
DEFENDING THIS CAPITOL AS WELL.
WE THINK ABOUT THE OTHERS WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES AND WERE
INJURED, AND EVERYONE LIVING
WITH THE TRAUMA OF THAT DAY.
THOSE DEFENDING THIS CAPITOL TO
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS IN BOTH
PARTIES AND THEIR STAFFS, TO
REPORTERS, CAFETERIA WORKERS,
CUSTODIAL WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
DON'T KID YOURSELF.
THE PAIN AND SCARS FROM THAT DAY
RUN DEEP.
SAID IT MANY TIMES, AND IT IS NO
MORE TRUE OR REAL THAN WE THINK
ABOUT THE EVENTS OF JANUARY 6th,
WE ARE IN A BATTLE FOR THE SOUL
OF AMERICA.
A BATTLE THAT BY T